لذا ، إنها فقط حوالي الساعة 3:00 صباحًا ، أرتدي قناعي وأعترف بالاندفاع بأنهم يضعون حدودًا لمدينة ووهان تحت إغلاق ووهان في الصين الآن قيد الإغلاق حيث تكافح البلاد مع الخوف من جائحة تدابير يائسة لمحاولة احتواء فيروس كورونا القاتل ، تم منع أكثر من 11 مليون شخص يعيشون في تلك المدينة الآن من المغادرة صعدوا للتو على متن قطار يغادر بكين ، وكانوا متجهين إلى هاه التي تعتبر نقطة البداية إذا كنت ستفعل هذا الفيروس التاجي ومن هنا جاء اسم ووهان التاجي. الأمر الأكثر إثارة للقلق الذي نتج عن كل هذا هو حقيقة أنه وفقًا لمسؤولي الصحة الصينيين ، تم تأكيد ذلك للانتشار من شخص إلى آخر من إنسان إلى إنسان ، كل واحد منهم لا ، لقد تمكن هان من ركوب القطار لمدة خمس ساعات ونصف الساعة نحن سنذهب لتسجيل الوصول والحصول على تقييم حقيقي لمعرفة ما تبدو عليه الأشياء هنا ، يمكنك أن ترى أنهم أغلقوا منطقة السوق بأكملها ولا يوجد أي نشاط تجاري على الإطلاق [موسيقى] نحن  اقترح أنه إذا لم يكن ذلك ضروريًا ،
فلا تأتي إلى ووهان
وللمقيمين في ووهان إذا لم يكن هناك شرط خاص
لا تترك ووهان يا خضراء حتى
حضر خان عامًا من منطقة أتلانتا بشأن
مسألة
كاراييلان جيفارا تشارلي ، أوه ، أهلا دونا
تعرف قبل مجيئي إلى هناك  من أنت ،
لذا فقد شقنا طريقنا إلى محطة القطار
هنا في ووهان ، أريد أن أعطيك
فكرة عن وجودنا
وخط طويل من الناس الساعة
4:15 صباحًا هنا ، لذلك وصلنا للتو
إلى القطار الثاني  محطة على
أمل اللحاق بقطار الساعة 7 صباحًا الذي نحفره كما
لو أن أربع ساعات ونصف الساعة رجوعًا إلى
بكين لاحظت على طول الطريق أن بعض
الأشخاص كانوا يصطفون وهي
تحاول ركوب السيارة بالسيارة ، لقد جعلناها
على متن القطار المغادرة  بعد فترة وجيزة لوجود بكين
على الأرض هناك في ووهان ،
لا يزال لدينا جهات اتصال
نتواصل معها في محاولة للتعرف على ما
يبدو عليه الأمر بالنسبة لهم الذين يعيشون في ظل هذا
الإغلاق الجزئي
والقيود التي يواجهونها الآن
مثل  حتى أن تكون قادرًا على حضور
التجمعات العامة والأماكن في
دور السينما وأثناء فترة
الاحتفالات التي يصعب للغاية
بالنسبة للبعض ، هذا هو الوقت الوحيد من العام
الذي يمكنهم فيه الاجتماع مع العائلة
، وقد تم تحطيم هذا بسبب
هذا الفيروس و  مخاوف متزايدة الآن ،
هناك بعض الصور التي
بدأت تظهر عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي
ساعدت حقًا في إظهار ما هو السرد
من داخل ووهان وشقيقها
اليائس وهو أمر مزعج إلى حد ما
في نفس الوقت أريد أن أطلعك على
بعض منها وأنا  يجب أن يخبرك أن
cNN لم تتحقق منها بشكل مستقل ولكن منتجينا مروا بها بدقة شديدة
وكانوا ينظرون إلى الصور
بالإضافة إلى اللهجات
ويعتقدون أنها أصلية أول ما أريد أن
أريكم إياه يعطينا  فكرة عن نقص
البنية التحتية بالنظر إلى
حشود تدفق الأشخاص الذين يرونهم
في بعض هذه المستشفيات ، هذه
خيام تم نصبها  على ما
يبدو خارج أحد
المستشفيات ، هذا ما يظهره الفيديو على ما يبدو لاستيعاب
التدفق الزائد في فيديو آخر ، إنها
عاملة رعاية صحية وهي امرأة تسير على طول
خط من مرضى فيروس كورونا
المحتملين وكتفهم إلى كتف في
في أماكن ضيقة وهي تصرخ
عليهم لاتباع إجراءات معينة
لكنها في نفس الوقت تخبرهم أيضًا
ألا يكونوا متوترين وهذا
الفيديو الأخير هنا هو رأي مريض وهذا
ما يبدو أنه يظهر من
تلقي العلاج في مستشفى في ووهان.  إنه أمر مزعج إلى حد ما ،
تخيل
أنك تتلقى العلاج هناك وتنظر
لأعلى وترى فريقك الطبي
أمامك جميعًا يرتدون بدلات خطرة ،
إنه أمر غير مريح لكنك لا تلوم
الطاقم الطبي لأنهم
يحاولون بالطبع  لحماية أنفسهم نظرًا
للتعرض الأخير حتى
للعاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية وما نعرفه أنهم
أصيبوا بفيروس كورونا أيضًا الآن
لاستيعاب كل هذا ما هي
الحكومة الصينية  لأداء جيد ، أعلنوا أنه
سيتم استثمار 144 مليون
دولار للمساعدة في
مكافحة فيروس كورونا ، ليس من الواضح كيف سيكون ذلك بالضبط ،
لكن ربما جزء منه يتعلق
ببناء مستشفى جديد
لأننا علمنا من خلال وسائل الإعلام الحكومية أن
هناك  تخطط لبناء مستشفى
والحصول على ستة أيام من الوقت وأريد أن
أريكم هذا الفيديو من وسائل الإعلام الحكومية
وقد تمت مشاركته أيضًا عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الصينية ، ويبدو أنه يُظهر بعض
مركبات البناء وهي تزيل الكثير في
ووهان ، ومن الواضح أنها هنا حيث هم
سيتم تشييد ذلك المستشفى خلال
الأيام القليلة المقبلة ووفقًا
لصحيفة الشعب اليومية التي ستفتح في
3 فبراير